destacaba también y dedicó bastantes
palabras el Rey Carlos III al papel de
la iglesia y de cómo iba a comprometerse
a respetar ese papel que juega la
iglesia
y buenas tardes es muy significativo que
lo haya hecho porque creo que subraya
una de las líneas que la trazado como
eje del discurso que es la idea de
continuidad ciertamente la corona es una
institución que incide Precisamente
políticamente en este punto sobre todo
la unidad y la continuidad el ser capaz
de atravesar las vicisitudes de la
nación a través de distintas personas
que se suceden en el poder pero que
encarnan un mismo destino y que le da un
aire de institucionalidad a la vida de
Los Monarcas el hecho de que él haya
hecho referencia a su fe religiosa y a
su compromiso con esa fe religiosa y a
la relación instituto institucional con
la iglesia de Inglaterra en un momento
en que la iglesia de Inglaterra
atraviesa por una situación francamente
difícil se está deshaciendo en muchos
aspectos indica Hasta qué punto es
consciente de que unas palabras como
esas
pueden causar la unidad que ahora mismo
se estaría perdiendo y de la misma
manera creo que se puede trasladar esto
al mensaje que lanza al país hay que
confiar en su tradición hay que confiar
en lo que son y mostrarse ante el mundo
una vez más de esa